[Music]  Kevin Smith wants to direct the new Star  Wars movie we got ahold of Kevin Smith's  audition tape take a look  no it would suck if you are a member of  a species that was so fat and squat they  just named your whole species after a  fat squat building Hut it's like hey we  noticed everyone on your species is kind  of Hut shaped so we're just gonna make  it easier we're gonna go ahead and call  your whole species huts it's obnoxious  it's not like all bananas penis fruits  you know hey I found that Twilight chick  you're right those two things in our  head felt just like boobs it was so hot  it was like she had four boobs I had  used the force to squeeze all of them  and she had this weird [ __ ] stamp it  was just these letters ee n e what do  you think that means  well it's a tattoo of a team right so  she's probably been tattooing  [Applause]  go attack  [Applause]